all right thank you you guys want to
know how how the universe works works so
I'm going to tell you first off I write
all the lines for field and Lawrence
what is the most mind-boggling thing
about black holes oh my gosh black holes
aren't cosmic vacuum cleaners that go
around sucking things up they're
actually closer to time machines a black
hole's gravity is so strong that when
you get near it time slows down and
actually comes to a standstill the time
would actually stop that to me is not
only the strangest thing about black
holes but maybe the strangest thing we
know I think it's because they're really
weird and people are really interested
in weird stuff we love sci-fi and black
holes are like sci-fi become real but
black holes are the most exotic things
in the universe light can't escape from
them they're basically holds in space
themselves apart from them being black
holes and by definition mind-boggling
they are so important in the overall way
the universe works that you could have
this thing that's so massive that not
even light can escape and at the same
time have it have impact in how galaxies
are formed our stars are formed what I
love about black holes is that there's a
region that surrounds it where nothing
can be still it has a black hole rotates
so does the space around the black hole
that's pretty cool
next when you look inside of the black
hole what happens does it spaghettify
the object that goes through it does it
crush it that that's transport it to
another way what can happen is you fall
into one what happens inside of a black
hole maybe we'll never know we've had
arguments at NASA about whether anything
really falls into a black hole because
time is so stretched out when you
approach it instead of thinking a black
hole is vacuum cleaner that goes around
sucking material up think of something
that moves around shifting material out
of time I think black holes really are
unanimously the coolest thing in the
universe
[Music]
you